for years and years and years the
federal reserve the central bank of the
united states it has had a two percent
inflation target sometimes it's above
that target sometimes it's below and
every once in a while they hit that two
percent inflation target now as we know
over the last two years in response to
the covid pandemic and a huge disruption
in supply chains the federal reserve and
politicians used undisciplined monetary
and fiscal policy to go ahead and create
enormous inflation we now are officially
sitting about 8.5 percent growth in
prices of consumer goods over the last
12 months and the unofficial numbers are
well into the teens
but now what we're gonna start to watch
is that people are gonna change the
narrative and what we saw this morning
on cnbc is just the start what you can
see here is an economist talking about
moving that federal reserve inflation
target from two percent to three percent
and if the federal reserve actually
comes out and says that it's gonna cause
a lot of problems now here's the exact
clip first to understand exactly what
we're talking about what would force
them to change their target and what
would that target be
so what will force them to change that
target is the recognition that by being
so late they can't get to that target
and that credibility is threatened they
will also worry that
by hitting the brakes too hard they may
push this economy not just into a
short-term recession but into a
longer-term recession
and they will be very tempted and lots
of people will push them to raise that
target from two to three
um and as a way out now that's not going
to be an easy way out and it's going to
be incredibly controversial but that's
that's what you get
when you waited too long to recognize
what inflation is and to take action we
should have started qt last year we
didn't and we're now being the
consequences of the fed being so late
mohammed if you're right and they do
that
what happens to gold and what happens to
crypto on that day
they both go higher in a world like that
now the reason why this is important is
because i moved from a two percent
inflation target to three percent it's a
50
increase that would basically be the
federal reserve the central bank putting
up their hands and saying we can't
possibly hit that 2 target anymore we
simply have to give in and change our
benchmark that's not exactly what you
want to hear if you're in the camp of
hoping that inflation comes down if all
of a sudden there's a fifty percent
increase from two percent to three
percent a lot of people are going to be
wondering what exactly is going on can
you all get inflation under control and
what will this new world look like if
inflation is now three percent on a
target basis
well that just means that investable
assets they're going to continue to rise
in price it's exactly what you heard
gold bitcoin real estate other types of
inflation edge assets they're only going
to do well in these types of
environments part of inflation isn't
just that it actually happens a lot of
it is that there's a confidence game
associated with it if they say that
inflation's supposed to be two percent
the market believes it if they then come
out and say that their new target is
three percent it'll shake the confidence
people will start to believe well if
they say that it's supposed to be three
percent they've had trouble hitting
their targets in the past maybe actually
real inflation is going to normalize at
four or five percent and if i'm holding
cash that's not good for me the world is
shifting right beneath our feet and
seeing things like this the federal
reserve changing their inflation target
be normalized in conversation in the
mainstream media
tells you to pay attention keep your
head on a swivel
as the world changes you're gonna have
to be informed you're gonna have to make
sure that you're changing your portfolio
to adapt to this brand new world holding
cash is probably not gonna be the
greatest idea
the words of ray dalio cash is trash
and i think that what we're going to
watch is a bifurcation of society
the 55 of people who have investable
assets they'll continue to be protected
from high degrees of inflation but the
45 of americans who have no investable
assets they're going to struggle
and i hope that you at home get informed
and learn that saving is for losers
moving forward and you have to learn to
invest in order to protect yourself lots
of different assets that you can buy but
ultimately you have to be informed to be
educated and to be paying attention
before you can start to allocate your
capital in hopes of securing your
financial security hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time